hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to faith chapter 2 this is
the sequel to that game that we played
faith chapter 1 you ready from our
scares of the type you never ever
expected my the priest ill Father Garcia
you are hereby instructed to release
michael davies from your custody and
return him to his home immediately Mr
and Mrs Davies had already been
contacted by our office a representative
of the church is currently on route to
their home to discuss compensation in
return for their discretion you will
meet our representative there and
accompany him back to Rome Cardinal
Gifford
that's not so good at least I still got
my crucifix Oh aha a mirror Oh demon
okay so I'm not the same as I was but I
might be very similar one day one day
day one do you mean day one because one
day more of a goal type of thing two
weeks okay two weeks oh I don't like
that I don't like that at all that is
dead that might be that might be the
worst thing I've ever seen in my life oh
you're still here
oh I would oh I was under the impression
that you weren't here anymore
[Music]
[Music]
okay I think I've stepped into a world
that I don't fully understand so I'm
just gonna pretend that like I know what
I'm doing
Oh demon get out of this child be cried
oh oh oh wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait oh oh oh oh oh
that's a problem oh that's a problem oh
it's a that's a problem that's a problem
uh uh uh also did you call me a pet hey
you leave him alone okay I don't know
why I did the dance right out of there
but I think that's the awkward dance
when you realize what you've done
hey am I the same as I was am on the
same woods that a woman oh oh notice the
current investigation being conducted at
Gallup cemetery by the state of
Connecticut Historical Society has been
postponed until further notice in the
interim we asked the public to avoid the
cemetery grounds the surrounding woods
any wildlife and any unidentified
persons roaming the area thank you for
your patience oh good god that's too bad
what
thank you I'm thrown right into the
cemetery grounds
I don't live by your rules I'm a freakin
rebel close the gate behind me because
I'm polite as hell you need to leave me
the hell alone if you're gonna come out
of MeV mins my crucifix is white now oh
hello
okay good good I was open I was on I
shook hands with the devil
wait I shook hands with the devil I
lived in the eye he looks like a
long-lost friend
here it oh this one deserves the voice
dearest disciple verily not everyone who
says Lucifer Lucifer shall inherit his
kingdom he must first counter his demon
you must then serve his demon he must
then walk among the childrens of men and
his demon thus shall you receive the
blessing of the unspeakable return to
the save family hmm
whenever you are in need of rest love
Gary thank you Gary save as in enter the
spirit and as in that's gonna save my
game oh hi aren't you lovely
aren't you beautiful aren't you just to
luck why am I just walking oh oh what oh
I'm sorry oh I'm sorry what did I just
see in my own reflection you're gonna
pardon me with that one hey how you guys
doing did your spirits just leave your
body oh okay that saved my game and
damned my soul I'm guessing okay cool
I mean do it yeah I'm in doing it I
don't know what else to say but I'm into
it I'm totally down with this I'm down
to clown okay what is that
that's got to be some good extra so oh
well link that handy-dandy I'm glad I
did that whatever that did it if there
are any repercussions to that actions I
would like to know about it as soon as
possible also an honor they didn't want
to investigate the cemetery it's really
hard to get why but who I was about to
shipping should be my drink okay
everything's fine I guess great good
that's normal whatever happened oh good
it's a dead end why did I even want to
be your an angel what is that a penis Oh
God
oh no no no no oh oh whacked me with
your penis you're no angel that I know
of
you are certainly no angel all right
okay you're sure yeah keep telling
yourself that oh boy oh boy wait oh I
got a dodge Oh AHA okay okay oh [ __ ] my
own anger my old insurer my ol antler
why am I here by the way there was no
premise for this one there was no
lead-up to this
nobody was thrilled when I got pregnant
not even a little happy even my doctor
seemed to be judging me each time I'd
leave the doctor's office I'd see this
strange woman across the street all
she'd do is stare at me and smile no
words just a big warm smile somehow it
made those visits a little more bearable
after I lost the baby I saw her again
across the street from my doctor's her
smile was as big as ever but somehow not
as warm and friendly as I remember
yesterday I was walking and was shocked
to see the woman standing in the middle
of the path now she was pregnant she
beckoned towards me
I followed her off the path into the
woods that's when I met Gary ah Gary
yeah Gary good ol gare-bear everybody
loves Gary who doesn't know Gary I'm
gonna save my game ah go don't wait what
hello okay cool I killed the demon and
one of these people are gone but that's
okay this is just a warm-up I'm sure
okay
hello oh hi Oh Oh what where Oh why are
you hiding in the clouds I'm sorry
excuse me
playing some sick game of Frogger here
uh I just killed a baby a ghost baby I'm
pretty sure we just killed a ghost baby
losing grandpa was the hardest thing
I've ever experienced we were really
close I cried about it for weeks that my
stepmom introduced me to some of her
friends they asked me would you like to
see your grandfather again I missed him
so much I was willing to try anything
that night my stepmom drove me to one of
her friends house they took me down to
the basement I saw my grandfather in
there only it wasn't actually him when I
tried to run they closed the basement
door and locked me in I can't remember
much else from that night my stepmoms
friends are always coming by the house
now they tell me I have a debt to pay
they say if they have worked for me to
do okay cool that's wait where'd the
heads go
[Music]
uh-oh where's this Oh
oh you sneaky sneaky you think you so
clever okay well I won't go there just
yet because I don't know the secret of
that and then I'm willing to bet the
game is gonna reveal that to me at some
point in the future but for now I'm not
gonna do it
hi just you left huh I mean there's two
eyes on the wall so I'm assuming that
there's gonna be do different things
that I gotta kill one of them is myself
I know that for true oh hello oh good
great great okay do I just go into the
woods now is that all I do oh you're
doing the thing too
oh you silly Billy so I'm willing to bet
I just got a guess around which foggy
way I'm supposed to go unless this tells
me which way I need to go right up left
up up right up left up up I'm pretty
sure that's got to be it right up left
up and up it's the statues in case that
wasn't clear the statues are telling you
whoa I saw oh okay [ __ ] no no no I'll
see you again
Bob not ah but you're not smart enough
for me I've been freed
no more overbearing father turned
violent alcoholic no more hiding my
bruises and cuts no more pills and
needles no more getting laughed at and
kicked around they'll never laugh at me
again by day my body withers away but by
night my mind explores forbidden worlds
of power knowledge guided by beings of
pure darkness I have been trusted with
the secret knowledge of the demons seal
I have learned the correct Condren sign
drawing the inverted star along the
rocks arranged in five first at the
top-left point and then down I will lure
them into the woods then I will show
them my power okay I don't know if
that's supposed to be like a hint as to
what I'm supposed to do but I'm gonna
guess that that's not necessarily too
important for me to know
[Laughter]
oh how you doing buddy oh ah man this
one's a lot trickier than the last one I
kind of like it though I like the the
trip eNOS it adds this other layer of
weirdness thing okay okay all right you
know it's fine that's normal
which one is you this is perfectly
normal but you're gonna need to tell me
which one of yous is the imposter I know
one of uses wanna uses the impasto okay
all right fine nunna use Oh Shi guard
well she guards the door the underground
purgatory
I have not seen her children fear all
right Gary what are you forever you say
Gare bear I'm sorry what was that
[Music]
I had to come back I had to walk through
the corn one last time I wasn't sure
what I would find the dogs the children
the thing that took them it had been
five years I couldn't even find the
little graves anymore I just walked in
the field until I found that stupid
grinning scarecrow as I listened to the
night wind blowing through the crops it
was like the Scarecrow was mocking me
I turned around to go back and that's
when I heard it was behind me well it
was more like I felt it I didn't dare
turn around which stood there me the
Scarecrow and the doomed child finally I
mustered up a tiny bit of courage and
turned to look it immediately fled into
the opposite direction crashing through
the rows of corn
I ran to what little I saw of it drained
the blood from my face and made my skin
crawl I say it's because whatever I was
looking at didn't have a face just a
bloody gaping hole gross you mean like
[Laughter]
that is a stupid scaring scarecrow okay
good Wow this has been an experience
this is great I'm so glad about this
it's great hey confess thy sins I I
lusted day one of our paranormal
investigation into the Old Snake Meadow
Hill Church we've got three cameras a
box of tapes and enough beer and beef
jerky to last us a week on our way in we
asked some of the locals about the
church it was mostly the stories we had
heard before evil spirits dragging
children into the cornfield and secret
tunnels under the chapel but there was
this spindly lady game that we hadn't
heard yet apparently it has to do with
summoning the spirit of a woman who used
to take care of the orphans back in the
50s it was even an old rhyme they told
us walk the church from room to room
then maybe you will see her she will
move when you do but never try to trick
her awesome we're gonna try the game
tonight as soon as we get settled in
yeah I'm sure that's uh yeah I'm sure
that's gonna go good
oh I'm sorry what's with the candles I
see the candles and I'm seeing patterns
but what's with the candles I see that
what is that
oh it's stairs okay okay
candles okay more candles oh hi oh I've
got a legendary crucifix this is really
gonna help me oh okay oh okay oh oh that
made my skin crawl I don't know why I
did not like that sam-i-am I did not
like green eggs and ham
Oh would you like oh oh why is this so
unsettling I don't get it
nine three shouldn't have come here
tapes missing large stuck behind
basement door hasn't come back yet
anyway why can't you leave wait why
can't you leave I need to confess I'm
sorry for okay okay um where am i where
am i oh hi you're crying
me too okay good great where is this go
to nowhere it just curtain opens for
some reason okay cool good good to know
good to know guys this good to know I'll
just be on my way I'll be on my way so I
need to bring the girl to you why
why would I do that is the question I
have because I don't see a need or a
benefit to doing that thusly the thing
that you're asking me I think that in
fact it's a bad idea just saying oh oops
I don't know what else to go to in the
church I don't think there would be
anything else down here there's got to
be something else in here that I can
find right maybe something else changed
how do I open this what about the the
stained glass oh that's the oh [ __ ]
there was something in there oh well I
got something 9 - we're gonna be rich
we've caught supernatural stuff on
camera before sure doors opening on
their own things falling off of shelves
but nothing like this tonight while we
were trying the spindly lady game again
one of the candles on the floor lit up
by itself as soon as Loras walked into
the room it was nuts and we got it all
on film we're gonna make a fortune
selling this to the TV stations okay
well judging by your other note that
you're going to write I'm willing to bet
that that didn't work out so good oh
[Applause]
really is it because I haven't gotten
that I didn't get the note yet Wow
alright so from now on any time a ghost
shows up I'm playing defensively first
oh what the oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] the spindly lady
don't you dare you miss me hey don't
even think about don't even think about
oh gosh you're like a machine gun
oh yeah that's good let's go uh karate'
Oh darkness surrounds the I'm aware I'm
kind of in Hell this is my final memoir
hastily scribbled on the page of The
Good Book
I now descend the staircase knowing full
well that she waits for me ahead
checking the eye old watch has revealed
something quite astonishing time doesn't
change down here as we know it on the
surface even now the hands don't move
past to God's work be done I've been to
where only the faintest light shine and
protect from things unspeakable god help
me father Clark a foolish old man
going mad in his dark prison ears
bleeding from the screams of a demon
okay good yeah
duds yeah it's good yeah it sounds good
ooh I should take a picture of that so
I'm tells me that's important
all right snapper Unni snip snap snore
blink and a selfie for good measure mmm
I'm looking good yeah sorry it's just
when you're this handsome you just can't
help it oh well time to consult that
picture here we go
a little bit of a Who am I trying to do
I don't know there was that thing that
said about you know the making of the
star and the whatnot and what have you
there is a to symbol it's here to two
o'clock Oh
[Music]
Oh what el
[Music]
Oh Oh my bones just explode out of my
ass put on him well I'm not I represent
sure well we're wrong cuz I feel as
though I'm following some kind of
instruction here oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] my bones don't move past
two o'clock I get that and I get what
you're saying but it's not making the
most sense hmm wait one two three
okay so just wants me to count right
four five six seven eight nine ten oh
I'm sorry I must be in the wrong room
mother of demons okay is that like
mother of dragons but different okay I'm
outside guess it's good this real good
stampede well God Mufasa oh hey oh boy
bad dead bodies bad daddies how you
doing three murdered in latest wave of
ritualistic killings sterling
Connecticut the bodies of three young
people were discovered in the woods
outside of Sterling last night and what
authorities are calling a ritualistic
murder
Sandra Atwood angel Nogales and Troy
Inglis are the names of the unfortunate
victims who apparently stabbed multiple
times and beheaded before being killed
in a pagan istic ritual pandemonium reg
NAT two of the victims bodies were also
partially burned although authorities
would not specify who the body mover
found several miles from Gallup Cemetery
where residents reported to tomb had
been desecrated
they also found trails of blood leading
off into the woods investigators would
not comment on whether or not these two
incidents could be related the
arrangement of the bodies into a
Ritualist pattern as well as the writing
of certain symbols in the blood matches
the South several murders that have
occurred in the Sterling area since 1986
the killings may be connected to last
week's brutal slaying of Amy Martin a 17
year old girl like John Ward Ward had
impersonated a priest to game Amy's
trust before luring her into the woods
and killing her
Gators are asking residents to report
any suspicious activity to the police
authorities are urging the people of
sterling did not mourn the loss of that
would Nogales in English because after
all they were degenerate devil
worshipping thugs who were hooked on
crack cocaine to the parents how does
the music known a time like that why
even conduct an investigation at all
that's what you would like to them to
think wouldn't you John they were just
three pathetic outcasts who got what
they deserved you actually did the
computer what the [ __ ] you can't do this
to be in the middle of it no you
actually did the community a favor when
you found them getting a high in that
tomb you stalked them through the graves
and killed them one by one you ignore
the cries for help their pleas for mercy
you poodles in the ruined drug-addicted
bodies and then chopped off their heads
because everybody knows that removing
that is the only way to kill a snake
well guess what John you cannot kill it
cannot be killed oh my god oh my god oh
my god oh boy oh boy oh boy I'm here
John oh oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh oh my oh my
god Oh
excuse my
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh oh I'm all good I'm all good baby I'm
all good don't worry about me I'm fine
don't know what you're talking about
oh okay gone real slow go well it can't
seem to all right cool
good can't seem to get up here okay I
can't get up there that's okay that's
okay how about I crucify the slope I
don't know I I am uncertain I am
uncertain and that's okay that is okay
just because I'm unclear does not mean
that everything is by ad you heard the
good word okay yay
death awaits oh good I was hoping for
that great good great good this is good
great Oh what is that an eyeball hello
uh-huh okay good
hey what's the red there nothing all
right cool good Satan lives great good
no okay male star what
[Music]
[Applause]
when see don't when she don't you when
you see it don't move okay good
everything's fine everything's fine
everything is fine
everything's fine oh I get a note when I
was boy my Nana used to tell me about
old legends of the Dragons trolls and
demons that lived up in the mountains of
Norway in those old tales the people
were never strong enough to kill the
monster so instead they would sacrifice
one of their own to appease it keep it
satisfied it was like a deal with the
devil one sacrifice per year so that the
Beast would not come down from the
mountain and slaughter the entire
village in one night there was no candy
store killer what we're dealing with is
not even human when I got separated from
the other officers I saw the damn thing
dragging what was left of Jenkins down
into its lair that's when I understood
the bums and the tweakers the ones with
grid and the child prostitute Runaways
they'll eventually come back to the
tunnels they always do it can have them
for all I care nobody wants them around
except maybe that thing and I tell you
what I hope to god it never gets tired
of them okay good attitude mister
officer ossifer that's a good attitude
glad you're here
without you we'd be doomed okay what
about going up here what does this do I
don't know where this goes but I don't
like it I don't like it I don't like it
nope don't like this nope don't like it
oh where the hell am I where the hell am
I where am I wait but I'm what if I were
actually wanted to go in the hole the
hole of death what if I wanted to go in
the hole of death Oh
go in the hole - I changed my mind about
the hole of death
hey is the Jenkins sound here hey
Jenkins yeah you do it
eh you dropped a flashlight aha oh I see
uh-huh okay this is good all right I see
I see good great okay good
nothing to see here I don't know I don't
know what I did I couldn't even see it
I couldn't even tell what it was I don't
like what who's that
you see lately oh what's with the kids
oh boy okay that's not good
hi well don't mind me here you come okay
ideas I don't know what I did I don't
even though I was down here great I
great I did it who are you you naked
great good great great okay okay yeah
here I am you better run away it's
priest John Ward coming at you hot and
heavy as hot and heavy as a priest good
what gleen exclaiming great good hey
they hate the light okay good to know
all right also who is they
oh [ __ ] oh wait wait wait wait wait whoa
wait oh god wait wait stop go away go
away go away all of you go away go away
go away go away yeah back off back off
you think you can speak on me yes there
is no yeah back up back up back up
what with the kid running away okay did
that get rid of them or are they still
gonna be a problem
I don't know where I'm going oh okay so
three things three seals I got okay
I got a key I don't know what the keys
for there's gonna be a [ __ ] if I die
really easily here which I better not Oh
Frick Oh Frick you can't do that you
can't just spawn on me okay so that was
one key and apparently that was the only
way to go here
okay so there's gotta be somewhere that
I can use this key I guess I could go
back maybe like farther back then then
I've been known to in the past maybe I
could go back the way we came somewhere
I don't know no it's blocked off now but
where am I supposed to go now I'm
unclear I'm a little lost
it's gonna let one of you get me come on
do it uh well I'm very dead yeah but
what does it all mean it's like wait are
you kidding me
you're saying it's locked now and then
but when I got the key you didn't do
anything for me what kind of what kind
of [ __ ] is that
oh you're locked now too huh okay I see
how this is you douches
okay all right so now I'm gonna be able
to go get the key and then come back and
actually unlock it because it wasn't
doing that before I'm not crazy okay
cool I'm in though okay yeah we saw you
go in for some little spoon okay all
right cool the 91st psalm you got it
Bubba [ __ ] you
[Music]
but babies are loose wheel at risk
little spoon okay I don't know if I
believe you
hey how you doing oh hi nice grabby
hands oh I don't like your face
Oh
before Christmas feel a bit spirited oh
I was supposed to do something about
that oh I was definitely supposed to do
something about that I definitely should
have done something in Spiritu sancti
I should I just go yeah I'll let I'll
die just cuz I feel like I should have
protected mister man there
boo speech such aha dig so deep O'Neill
is probably for the booth speech such aa
big so it will be lid fugly further
boost each such a hard thing so people
even ugly hey we did it
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa what the heck
a good big papa
[Music]
a puddle whoa big papa
Oh Big Poppa
Oh God big papa you got a browser press
it oh [ __ ]
blah but oh god oh boy
man this is late is not happy
Oh God I don't know what I was supposed
to do about that one hoo boy
okay you stop that stop that is there a
way that he could survive because I well
there was nothing I could do about that
one oh how did you dodge that dude how
are you still alive and why are you of
no help oh oh okay the morning breaks I
was all a dream
so just a dream yeah John I can't do
this anymore I'm sorry
I will always love you back that's a
weird thing to say okay all right cool
who are you Karen Karen really I'm not
going in there apparently I won't go in
there I won't do it you can't make me I
won't do John we don't have much time
the profane Sabbath is almost upon us if
they find Nate and Jason they will
perform a ritual on them to call forth a
demon of unspeakable power the name of
the demons Malthus I am in the process
of discovering their whereabouts I will
contact you again soon we must not let
them do to the boys what they did to
Aimee father Garcia
oh my light mirrors are conceived worst
wars ever since I left that house how
they parted my missions of demons I
finished my work with it boys are in
danger my muscle mouth Ausmus beasts are
stopped as a little food samples go sir
sorry curse of darkness no doctor this
will be part of it okay wait is this the
end
hey wait a minute go forth with furs but
what are the ready could their affair
not but there was a bunch of other
routes that could have taken but there
you have it gone anyway yeah that's
pretty cool
I can't wait for chapter three I know
they were talking about Chapter three
coming soon but this is pretty cool it's
just amazing what they can pull off with
such simple graphics so anyway thank you
everybody so much for watching if you
have not seen the first part go watch it
there's a link in the description it's
called faith chapter one go check it out
it's really cool and this was really
cool too so thank you everybody so much
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next video
[Music]